in a lot of ways unfortunately what
happened last night could not have been
worse for this country for
children for grandchildren for a future
the outcome of our presidential election
was seized from the hands of voters
where of course it rightly belongs
and now resides in the control of
lawyers and courts and highly partisan
clearly corrupt big city bureaucrats
so no matter what happens next that is a
tragedy
many americans will never again accept
the results of a presidential election
that story is still unfolding tonight
obviously we're going to follow it as
honestly as we can wherever it leads
we'll begin with that in just a minute
but first we want to acknowledge the
good news and believe it or not there is
some good news regardless of everything
else that has happened
and here it is america remains it's
still
here that's the first and most important
thing and it's not a foregone conclusion
we almost lost it
democrats told us they wanted to beat
donald trump they spent more money than
anyone
ever has in any election in history to
do that
but there was a lot more going on
democrats didn't harness the full power
of big
tech and the billionaire class simply to
make joe biden president
no what they really wanted was total
control over
everything no more democracy no more
dissent
permanent obedience from the rest of us
and they came
shockingly close to getting that if
democrats had won the white house
and the senate last night the country as
we know it would have ended not because
democrats have bad ideas though they do
but because democrats plan to impose an
entirely new system
on our country not an agenda a system
with nothing to check their power the
left fully intended to eliminate the
traditional american balances within our
government
along with the constitution and the bill
of rights that constrain their power
we're not overstating this joe biden's
party planned to turn
our highest court into a partisan
political weapon
they admitted that they wrote magazine
articles about how they planned to do it
then they planned to pack the congress
of the united states a legislative
branch
by adding new states to our union purely
for the senate seats
we're not speculating there either they
admitted that too
then they planned to pack the electorate
itself the ultimate
corruption in a democracy 20 million
foreign nationals added to our voter
rolls overnight
that was their agenda how would any of
that improve
the united states of america well they
never claimed that it would
making this country better was never the
point the point was to create a
permanent
democratic majority a one-party state
with complete control over the
population
never in our history has any mainstream
political party proposed an agenda
more radical than this they didn't talk
about it much there's a reason for that
of course
they didn't want to scare you but it was
entirely real
and last night it came very close to
happening
we should all be deeply grateful that it
didn't
we're telling you this because we want
to be clear about the stakes involved
this isn't a matter of opinions and a
difference between those opinions
this isn't about policy it's about the
system
that all of us live under that governs
this country
that's what's at stake so keep that in
mind as we move forward